for whatever reason the establishment
media they don't care too much about us
podcasters and online shows and it's
probably because we're not nearly as big
as a lot of people think we are if
you're watching shows like this you
assume we are the Big Show but we're
probably not
probably not Tucker Carlson he's a big
show but then again he's a big show
Mostly among the older crowd and his uh
view his audience in the key demo is
actually comparable to ours a little bit
more that's why I think it's interesting
that he's getting so much heat over
what's going on but I but I get it he's
a big cable TV news Prime Time host to
put out definitive proof showing that
the January 6 committee Democrats in the
media were lying about what happened on
January 6th they began lying about what
Tucker Carlson actually said and
reported on and now we have Chuck
Schumer complaining about it Elon Musk
roasting him and Democrats and we
actually have the view saying what
Tucker Carlson did should be illegal